We'll reject h not, because our t statistic is huge. We know that this will
fall well beyond the t-critical value no matter what significance level we
choose, the smallest usually being 0.01. We reject h-not because the
probability of getting this T statistic? In other words the probability of
getting this sample mean from a population with mean six point zero seven is
very, very small. That's the p value. It's the probability of getting this
value if the null hypothesis is true. Since the probability is so small, then
there must be something else going on. The null hypothesis is probably not
true. Finches with this beak width come from an entirely new population. Not
equal to 6.07 as the mean.